hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play charge okay um
I downloaded this game and I saw it in
my folder and I have no idea why or
where or when I got it
so um you're going on the same
exploratory adventure that I am so here
we go find out how to play I get big I'm
guessing it has something to do with
defibrillators and that looks a little
ominous oh I'm supposed to shock myself
until I can run around what really
really my objective is to run around and
shock myself so that I can stay alive
and if I run out of things I guess I die
it's like um it's like crank the movie
crank I've never seen the movie crank
but I know what it's about you got to
keep your heart rate up Earl's oh no oh
this should be interesting like I said I
don't know where a guy's so hopefully
there's a link in the description below
if not um send me something try to get
the link to me if you guys have found it
and it's not there but I'm pretty sure
it'll be there alright here we go
hey dude what's in here oh hello can i
shock myself on experience I can am I
just supposed to build up maximum charge
or am I just looking for other stuff
here ha ha ha
what was it here is that Harry
partridges Snape there I'm not sure what
that is okay I just gotta zap myself
until what what whoa what's the point
oh hello Scooby oh this is some strange
Hospital ha ha
Oh Pete there tasering me thank you
gimme ha ha
what did I just suck the life out of
that patient or something I think I did
what him what is going on and
this is so weird my voice is a little
hoarse why is that guy rolling on the
round and if I can see his butt oh he's
dead
that's why ah gimme either charge
well I see I think I think look the
Gurney's are just like whoa whoa ah oh I
was supposed to go in a room when that
happened f game is messed up but awesome
I love it I like this game this is kind
of fun I think is real they're really
fun is like it's like a a really well
done running game or like any any of
those I bet this could be like
translated into an iPhone game pretty
easily I don't know that's probably oh I
don't know what I think it's made on the
Unity engine so I'm betting it could
whoa hey hi got all the way to [ __ ]
complete it to be I remember what there
where that Snape a picture comes from
it's from well I don't remember who made
the cartoon but it's where Ron Weasley
is trying to learn how to do ring when
we all do the little your chalk I don't
know why there's an O'Neill it's going
right through the hospital but whatever
I really go away I need to go somewhere
where I'm not exactly sure but I'm going
there yep
yeah Bob rip rubber beer I need to
actually get charges um to keep my heart
rate up so I can't just get boots off of
these other guys perv dude
oh come here come on come here
roll it around on the ground Wingardium
Leviosa
Oh wink it's not wrong wheelie it's
Wingardium Leviosa
your show Oh
Wingardium Leviosa
Oh win card in play if anyone hasn't
seen a queer that cartoon you're
probably better off not seeing it it's
it's it's uh that's weird just like most
of the cartoons that guy makes I can't
remember who made it but I neveri well
known ID I'm bad with names I'm running
out of people there's less and less got
a cape to heart right up no matter what
gotta keep it going
I still don't know if there's like a
high-score system enabled or like
there's some sort of end game that I'm
after I can't I don't think so I don't
think I'm actually going anywhere I
think it's just infinite we okay these
security guards really aren't doing my
ha then I can tell that my oh another
one well I guess there's not much that
to the game that I can show you if there
is an ending and you guys decide to play
it I'm pretty sure the game is free cuz
I don't remember paying for it I usually
remember when I pay for a game so I'm
pretty sure that this one is free so I'm
just gonna look at the credits here real
quick it's a wild grass game made by
James Ferguson
Matthew Korver parisa Narus Alex Short
and Tom Spratt special thanks to Rick
headwords
that's it okay no more special thanks so
it's a very small game but it actually
is pretty fun it's kind of fun just to
run down the hallway and barrel through
people and just get shocked alive and
once again my voice is kind of hoarse I
was at the bar yesterday yelling a lot
so it's a lot deeper than it usually is
a little lot bigger than it really is
Oh Wingardium live you saw and go see
that cartoon I'll try to remember what
that is too so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and damn daylight
saving time for losing me
and as always I will see you in the next
video
ah
knock on door
Oh
Oh
Kludd
Oh
you